Wow a house hi I'm Garrett and I'm Nikki
no no no you did a great job
Wow a house hi I'm Garrett and I'm Nikki
we're fascinated by how other people
live and we're gonna try to find the
really interesting living situations and
live there experiencing a totally new
lifestyle thing is we don't really know
each other that we don't know but we're
gonna live together with total strangers
this week we're living in a communal
posture hi welcome to pause here thank
you so much podshare is a cool living
co-working community across multiple
addresses in the city of Los Angeles wow
this is beautiful this is huge yes I
don't know why I thought this would be
small we live small but like in a big
space but with a lot of people so since
2012 we have hosted over 10,000 people
across the world for any duration of
time you can stay one night say multiple
months you really doesn't matter as long
as you're open to sharing
there's toiletries in the bathroom and
then there's food in the kitchen
so anything marked shared you guys can
eat at any point and then the big rule
at podshare is the quiet hours so after
10 p.m. and until 10 a.m. please turn
your phones to vibrate and whisper since
the tiny house basically Nikki and I
arrived back at work and split off in
different directions I don't think we've
talked very much other than for the
video yeah I don't know what he's been
doing for the last few weeks these are
the pods my goodness
so here we have 38 38 huh
what makes the pods different than bunk
beds is this their way and this is
something you'll never find in any like
bunk bed or like we hate the word so I'm
gonna say it for like just one time like
we can't cost them the goal of podshare
is actually to be the first subscription
housing model in the city of Los Angeles
and in the state of California and then
the country but imagine paying one
monthly fee and living anywhere in the
country or maybe the world that's what a
global citizen is 25 and 27 I want the
Sun sure obvious 25 these are like adult
bunk beds drugs like this is totally
fine right I think this is about Garrett
let's do it how many siblings is Niki
have crap Jamie I'm gonna say I think
Nikki has two sisters I'm gonna say he
has a sister don't think Nikki hasn't
known man but her full name is Nicola
Garrett's middle name is Martin Martin
I'm TV ooh these are 22 inch flat
screens and you guys have HBO go Netflix
HBO yeah you can watch your favorite
shows yes okay as we felt a community is
like a circle and it's an open floor
plan we're like you see me I see you so
trust is established nobody
no pod sex is hot sex that's a joke or a
rule no goals for the pod chair Garin I
have to make a friend a total stranger
that I do not know right now I want to
be friends with them - and this one's
probably gonna be very hard I want to
get invited to Nikki's wedding people
want to share - in a pod they have these
double size policies queen-size pods
oh but still notes your process so here
there are four toilets and there's three
showers and it's all co-ed so you guys
can use first-come first-serve I think
one of my goals is to see if maybe
anyone would be interested in Garrett
she's getting married in like a month so
it's kind of late in the game but if she
and I can become close enough friends
that she feels bummed that I'm not gonna
be at her wedding
that shows big progress in our
relationship and he believes in love he
did tell me that so maybe he will find
love in this pod sure no this such a
great space and this come on at night
and then it's pretty Zen you live here
yeah permanently I Paul chair yes so
like I'll crash at any part I don't have
an apartment Wow
will I ever have my own apartment again
I wonder so I don't ma'am but I could
put it up on that little hook up there
go ahead we're here in the watcher in
Venice we're literally in my pod it's
like five feet between your bed and mine
yeah like and my feet hang off like -
that's too small for you everything is
too small for me in this world I need to
change into pants because it's a hundred
degrees and I want to wear my shorts
there's just a little closet right here
yeah I don't think that's what it's for
but maybe I can
I can guard the closet for you back in
the closet all right Oh God yeah when we
first got here I was very nervous it's
one thing to live with you you're one
person but know there's a lot of people
I have to live with a lot of boys yeah
so you've gone from living with one boy
once to now living with a lot of pie
like 20 boys is this how you're gonna
change all the time okay you're good
wait let me out that was like the worst
magic trick ever
it's like a very ecology vibe it's a
very social vibe and I'm just kind of
hanging out walking around like it could
be really fun they're talking about
doing barbecue tomorrow we can play
volleyball and basketball and ping-pong
like I feel like a little kid at summer
camp it really does feel like summer
camp if we're going to be living with
what is it 36 other people I'm gonna see
how many of them I can meet like how
many people I can shake their hands
oh so that's good god that's so many
people alive people hey champ
hi how goes making a friend I just need
some time I don't think there is such a
thing as sometimes it's just different
for you and for me to meet that's true
all right if you want time to yourself
I'm gonna go meet this person
- hi - Garret
nice to meet you Julia what are you
working on so far I think I'm liking
this more than Nikki everybody here is
like really friendly and I'm really
starting to get the hang of the communal
living aspect I'm kind of exhausted
meeting people and being invested in
meeting people is personally exhausting
it's not something that comes easily to
me okay have a good night George me see
like if I were home right now I'd be
like playing video games in my underwear
so far I think I'm making more progress
with the total strangers than I am with
Nikki I think she's kind of in an
uncomfortable position with so many
strangers I don't blame her
it's pretty uncomfortable this space is
the only space that belongs to me and
like anyone could look inside which is
crazy there's like no space to retreat I
need to not think about what others
think of me right now even though I've
got like 36 roommates the roommate I'm
most focused on is Nikki can I hear it
well psych 7 a.m. it's too bright for me
you keep sleeping since I can keep
sleeping we go for a run so far this
Tommy you lifestyle has me a little
healthier I woke up this morning and
just like immediately like you roll over
and you can see like six people sleeping
Darrin and I are gonna make breakfast
we've got some avocado toast and
hopefully other people will want to
share with us and we'll make some new
friends
trying to see if something wants these
it's a good way for you to make a friend
would you like an avocado toast okay
that's okay
no worries anyone want some avocado
toast
no okay hey miss can I just eat this one
no hoping everyone ate already always
how did you sleep
that's okay yeah while fall asleep the
barbecue tonight
oh man I said I should invite Kelsey
you're on a meet her
yeah I love you oh you gonna teach me
how to play volleyball today
for realsies yep bump set spike yeah put
your hands together like this and then
fold them over okay
thank you let's use that other ball the
best strategy is to just make sure the
ball goes high and in the middle of your
side Oh Nikki does that she's good she's
very good my goals were to make a friend
I've done my goal I've made a friend who
will come and get matcha with me so we
did it but I think I changed my goals I
have not yet gotten invitation to a
wedding try and get to know some people
a little bit better make it a favor goal
just like do better at saying hi to
people there's a big barbecue tonight so
I think that'll help
I think her fiance's coming to this
barbecue tonight and maybe if I work on
her fiance one of them will invite me to
the wedding so nice a lot of major guys
come to your wedding
well I'm sorry was that forward you
should get some food and talk over that
anyway and he just get some food I mean
you can't come with you
what I mean we're not would you actually
call it where is it I don't know it's in
Washington State okay if you'd really
like to sure I think I did way better
today we had that barbecue in the
backyard jumped into a bunch of
different conversations I met a bunch of
new people and it really it's not as bad
once I just kind of dive in and do it
I'm really proud of Nikki though because
she like really grew to like meet people
and like gain this confidence of like
she can go up to anybody and talk to
them now it was like really cool and I
got an invitation to the wedding I'm an
introvert it's Who I am
but every once in a while we can do this
but then I just got to go back gotta go
home living a pod share is great you're
gonna meet so many interesting people
that are gonna come through your life
that you would never have encountered
you're gonna become a better person for
living here like this place is so unique
being around so many people and him
being the person I know the most I think
has really brought us closer together no
matter what if I can find Garrett
there's someone who knows me it made me
like trust him more I think for sure I
did not get anyone to hook up with
Garrett though
so that's only so much I can do
you're never lonely but you're never
alone that's it I can't I got to leave
we got to get out of here
I want to just take a shower without
wearing sandals and at some point I'm
gonna need to masturbate bipod chair my
pond chair
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]